the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so welcome back we're gonna
finish this chapter on maximum
likelihood estimation and last time I
briefly mentioned something that was
called Fisher information alright so
Fisher information in general is
actually a matrix when you have a
multivariate parameter theta so if theta
for example is d by D is the dimension D
then the Fisher information matrix is
going to be a D by D matrix all right
you can see that because it's the outer
product so it's of the form gradient
gradient transpose right so if it's
great in gradient transpose the gradient
is d dimensional and so gradient times
get into gradient transpose is a d by d
matrix okay and so this in fact this
matrix is actually contains well tells
you it's called Fisher information
matrix so it's basically telling you how
much information about theta is who is
in your model all right
so for example if your model is very
well parameterised then you will have a
lot of information you will have a
higher so let's think of it as being a
scalar number just one number now so
you're gonna have a larger information
about your parameter in the same
probability distribution but if you
start having a weird way to parameterize
your model then the Fisher information
is actually going to drop so as a
concrete example think of for example a
parameter of interest in a Gaussian
model where the mean is known to be zero
but what you're interested is in the
variance Sigma squared all right if I'm
interested in Sigma square I could
traumatize my model by Sigma Sigma
squared Sigma to the 4 Sigma to the 24 I
could permit raised it by whatever I
want then I would have a simple
transformation then you could say that
some of them are actually more or less
informative and you're gonna have
different values for your Fisher
information all right so let's just
review a few well-known computations
right so I will focus
primarily on the one-dimensional case as
usual and I claim that there's two
definitions so if theta is a real valued
parameter then there's basically two
definitions that you can think of for
your Fisher information one involves the
first derivative of your log likelihood
and the second one involves this second
derivative all right so the log
likelihood here were actually going to
define it as L of theta and what is it
well it's simply the likelihood function
for one observation all right so it's L
and I'm gonna write one just to make
sure that we all know we're talking
about one observations of which is the
order again everything it's X and theta
right all right so that's the log
likelihood remember okay so for example
if I have a density what is it gonna be
it's gonna be log of F sub theta of X
okay so this guy is a random variable
because it's a function of a random
variable all right and that's why you
see expectations of this thing it's a
random function of theta all right if I
view this as a function of theta the
function becomes random because it
depends on this random X all right and
so I have theta is actually defined as
the variance of L prime of theta okay so
the variance of the derivative of this
function and I also claim that it's
equal to negative the expectation of the
second derivative of theta okay and here
the expectation and the variance are
computed because this function remember
is random right so I need to tell you
what is the distribution of the X with
respect to which I'm computing the
expectation and the variance and it's
the theta itself okay so typically the
theta we're going to be interested in so
there's an information a Fisher
information for all values of the
parameter but the one typically we're
interested in is the true parameter
okay theta star all right but view this
is a function of theta right now right
so now I need to prove to you and this
is not a trivial statement right the
variance of the derivative is equal to
negative the expectation of the second
derivative I mean there's really quite a
bit that comes into this right and it
comes to the from the fact that this is
a log not of anything is the log of a
density so let's just prove that without
having to bother too much ourselves with
some technical assumptions I'm actually
and the technical assumptions are the
assumptions that allow me to permute
derivative an integral right because
when I compute variances and
expectations I'm actually integrating
against the density and what I want to
do is to is to make sure that I can
always do that right so my technical
assumptions are I can always permute
integral and derivatives okay so let's
just prove this so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna assume that X has density F
theta okay and I'm actually just gonna
write well let me write it F theta right
now okay let me try to not be lazy
writing okay and so the the thing I'm
gonna use is the fact that the integral
of this density is equal to what 1 and
this is where I'm gonna start doing
where things that means that if I take
the derivative of this guy its equal to
0 right so it means that if I look at
the derivative with respect to theta of
integral F theta of X DX this is equal
to zero and this is where I'm actually
making this this switch is that I'm
gonna say that this is actually equal to
the derivative of the integral of the
derivative ok
so that's going to be the first thing
I'm gonna use and of course it fits true
for the first derivative it's gonna be
true for the second derivative so I'm
gonna actually do it a second time in
the second thing I'm going to use is the
fact that the integral of the second
derivative is equal to zero ok so let's
start from here and let me start from
say the expectation of the second
derivative F at L say L prime T prime
theta so what is L prime prime theta
well it's the second derivative of log
of s theta of X ok and we know that the
derivative of the log sorry the yeah so
the derivative of the log is 1 over well
it's the derivative of F divided by F
itself ok
everybody's with me
okay just log of F prime is f prime over
F okay here is just that F I've used
this as a function of theta and not as a
function of X okay so now I need to take
another derivative of this thing so
that's going to be equal to well right
so the we all know the formula for the
derivative of the ratio so I pick up the
second derivative times F theta minus
the first derivative squared divided by
F theta squared okay
basic calculus and now I need to check
that negative the expectation of this
guy is giving me back what I want okay
well what is negative the expectation of
L prime prime of theta well what I need
to do is to do negative integral of this
guy against F theta so it's minus the
integral of
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay that's just the definition of the
expectation right I take an integral
against F theta but here I have
something nice that's happening is that
those guys are canceling right and now
that those guys are cancelling those
guys are canceling too okay so what I
have is that the first term I'm gonna
break this difference here right so we
say that the integral of this difference
is the difference of the integrals so
the first term is going to be the
integral of D over D theta squared F
theta right and the second one the
negative settings are gonna cancel and
I'm gonna be left with what this okay
varies following anybody found the
mistake
about the other mistake I don't know if
there's mistake I'm just trying to get
you to check what I'm doing okay with me
so far so this guy here is the second
the integral the second derivative of f
of X DX what is this it's zero and
that's because of this guy which I will
call frowny face
okay so front face tells me this okay
and let's call this guy monkey that
hides his eyes now let's just do
something simpler let's go to star and
this guy we will use later on okay so
okay so now I have to prove that this
guy which I have proved is equal to this
is now equal to the variance of L prime
theta okay so now let's go back the
other way right we're gonna meet halfway
I'm gonna have a series I want to prove
that this guy is equal to this guy and
I'm gonna have a series of inequality
qualities that I'm gonna meet halfway
okay so let's start from the other end
right we started from the negative L
prime prime theta let's start with the
variance part okay variance of L prime
of theta so that's the variance okay so
that's the expectation of L prime of
theta squared minus the square of the
expectation of L prime of theta okay now
what is the square of the expectation of
L prime of theta well L prime of theta
is equal to the partial with respect to
theta of log F theta of X
which we know from the first line over
there that's what's in the bracket on
the second line there is actually equal
to the partial over theta of f theta X
divided by F theta X right that's the
derivative of the log so when I look at
the expectation of this guy I'm going to
have the integral of this against F
theta and the F Thetas are gonna cancel
again just like they did here okay so
this thing is actually equal to the
integral of partial over theta of f
theta of X DX okay and what is this
equal to zero by the monkey hiding is
hice okay so that's star tells me that
this is equal to zero okay so basically
when I compute the variance this term is
not gonna matter I only have to compute
the first one
[Applause]
okay so what is the first one well the
first one is the expectation of L prime
squared right and so that's that guy is
the expected is the integral of well
what is L prime again it's partial over
partial theta F theta of X divided by F
theta of X now this time this guy is
squared against the density so one of
the F Thetas cancel but but now I'm back
to what I had before for this guy all
right so this guy is now equal to this
guy
right there's just the same formula so
they're the same thing and so I've moved
both ways starting from the expression
that involves the expectation of the
second derivative I've come to this guy
and starting from the expression that
tells me about the variance of the first
derivative I've come to the same guy
right so that completes my proof are
there any questions about the proof all
right we also have on our way found an
explicit formula for the Fisher
information as well right so now they
have this thing I could actually add
that if X has a density for example this
is also equal to the integral of well
the partial over theta
of F theta of X squared divided by f
theta of X right because they just prove
that those two things were actually
equal to the same thing which was this
guy all right now in practice this is
really going to be the useful one
the other two are gonna be useful
depending on on what piece here all
right so if I asked you to compute the
Fisher information you have now three
ways to pick from and basically practice
will tell you which one to choose if you
want to save five minutes when you're
doing your computations okay maybe
you're the guy who likes to take
derivatives and then you're gonna go
with the second derivative one maybe you
like the guy who likes to expend square
so you're gonna take the one that
involves the square of the of the Spirit
Prime and maybe you're just a normal
person and you want to use that guy
all right so okay why do I care
right this is the Fisher information and
I could have defined there he got
information by taking in the square root
of this guy plus the sine of this thing
and just be super happy and have my name
in textbooks but this thing is a very
particular meaning when we're doing the
maximum likelihood estimation
all right so remember the maximum
likelihood estimation is just an
empirical version of trying to minimize
the KL divergence right so what we're
trying to do maximum likelihood is
really trying to minimize the KL
divergence all right all right so we're
trying to minimize this function
remember so now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna plot this function we said
that let's place ourselves in cases
where this KL is convex so that the
inverse is concave right so it's gonna
look like this right you shaped let's
convex okay so that's the true thing and
trying to minimize and what I said is
that I'm gonna actually try to estimate
this guy so in practice I'm gonna have
something that looks like this but it's
not really this and we're not gonna do
this but you can show that you can
control this uniformly for over the
entire space that there's no space where
it just becomes huge in particular this
is not the space where it just becomes
super huge and then the minimum of the
deaded line becomes really far from this
guy okay so if those two functions are
close to each other and then this
implies that the minimum here of the
dotted line is close to the minimum of
the of the solid line okay so we know
that this is theta star and this is our
MLE estimators theta hat ml okay so
that's basically the principle the more
data we have the more accurate the more
the closer the dotted line is to the
solid line and so the minimum is closer
to the minimum but now there's this is
just one example right where I drew a
picture for you but there could be some
really nasty examples think of this
example where I have a I have a function
which is convex but it looks more like
this
okay let's comebacks right you shaped
it's just uh you know it's a
professional you now I'm gonna put a
dotted line around it that has pretty
much the same fluctuations right the
band around that is of this size right
so do we agree that the distance between
the solid line and the dotted line is
pretty much the same in those in those
two pictures right now here depending on
how I tell this guy basically I can put
the minimum theta star wherever I want
and let's say that here I actually put
it here okay that's pretty much the
minimum of this line and now the minimum
of the dotted line is this guy right so
they're very far the fact that I'm very
flat at the bottom makes my requirements
for being close to the u-shaped solid
curve much more stringent if I want to
stay close and so this is the canonical
case this is the annoying case and of
course you have the you know awesome
case alright looks like this and then
whether you deviate you can have like
something that moves pretty far it
doesn't matter it's always going to stay
closed now what is the quantity that
measures how curved I am at a given
point how curved the function is at a
given point the second derivative and so
the Fisher information is negative the
second derivative why the negative
because we're well here yeah we're
looking for a minimum and this guy is
really the you should view this as a
reverted function right we're not this
is we're trying to maximize the
likelihood which is basically maximizing
the negative KL so the picture I'm
showing you is trying to minimize the ko
so the truth picture that you should see
for this guy is the same except that
it's just flipped over okay but the
curvature is the same whether I flip my
by a sheet or not
okay so
same thing so apart from this negative
sign which is just coming from the fact
that we're maximizing instead of
minimizing this is just telling me how
curved my likelihood is around the
maximum and therefore it's actually
telling me how good how robust my
maximum likelihood estimator is it's
going to tell me how close
actually my likelihood estimator is
gonna be a maximum likely is going to be
to the true parameter so I should be
able to see that somewhere all right
there should be some statement that
tells me that this Fisher information
will play a role when assessing the
precision of the cesta mater and
remember how do we characterize a good
estimator well we look at its bias or we
look at its variance and we can combine
the two informed ecstatic risk so
essentially what we're gonna try to say
is that one of those guys either the
bias or the variance or the quadratic
risk is going to be worse if my function
is flatter meaning that my Fisher
information is smaller okay and this is
exactly the point of this last theorem
so let's look at a couple conditions
alright so this is this is your typical
you know 1950 statistics paper that has
like one page of assumptions and this
was like that in the early days because
people were trying to make theories that
would be valid for as many models as
possible and now people are sort of
abusing this and they're just making all
this list of assumptions so that their
particular method works for the
particular problem because they just
want to take shortcuts all right but
really this ones this is you know
maximum likelihood estimator is
basically as old as modern statistics
and so this was really necessary
conditions and we'll just parse them the
model is identified well better be
because I'm trying to estimate theta not
P theta all right so this one's good for
all theta the support of p theta does
not depend on theta all right so that's
just something that we need to have
otherwise things become really messy and
in particular I'm not gonna be able to
define likelihood kill back libeled i've
urgencies alright then why can I do that
well because the kullbackleibler
divergence has a log of the ratio of two
densities and if one of the support is
changing with theta as it might be they
have the log of something that's 0 over
something that's not zero and log of
zero is a slightly annoying quantity to
play with okay and so we're just
removing that case nothing depends on
theta think of it as being basically the
entire real line as a support for
gaussians for example theta story's not
on the boundary of theta can anybody
tell me why this is important we're
talking about derivatives all right so
when I want to talk about derivatives
I'm talking about fluctuations around a
certain point and if I'm at the boundary
it's actually really annoying I might
have the derivative remember I give you
this example where the maximum
likelihood is just detained at the
boundary because the function cannot
grow anymore at the boundary but it does
not mean that the first order derivative
is equal to zero it does not mean
anything all right so all this picture
here is valid only if I'm actually
achieving the minimum inside because if
I mean if my my theta space stops here
and it's just this guy I'm gonna be here
and there's no questions about curvature
or anything that comes into play it's
completely different
so here it's inside okay again think of
theta as being the entire real line that
everything is inside I is invertible
what does it mean for a positive number
a one by one matrix to be invertible
yeah
a one by one matrix that's a number
right what is the characteristics with
numbers and I ask you if it's invertible
what are you going to do with it check
if the determinant is zero what is the
determinant of the one by one matrix
it's just the number itself right so
that's basically we want to check if
this number is zero or not okay so we're
gonna think in the one dimensional case
here and in the one dimensional case
that just means that the curvature is
not zero well it better be not zero
because then I'm gonna have no
guarantees if I'm totally flat if I have
no curvature and basically totally flat
at the bottom and then I'm gonna get
nasty things now this is not true I
could have a curvature which grows like
so here it's basically the the second
derivative is telling me if I do the
Taylor expansion it's telling me how I
grow as a function of say x squared
right this is the quadratic term that
I'm controlling it could be that this
guy is zero and then the term of order X
to the four is picking up all right that
could be the first one that's nonzero
but that would mean that my rate of
convergence would not be square root of
n what I'm actually applying central
limit theorem it would become n to the
1/4 and if I have all a bunch of zero
until the 16th order I would have n to
the 1/16 because that's really telling
me how flat I am okay so we're gonna
focus on the case where it's only
quadratic terms and the rates of the
central limit theorem is kickin all
right and then a few other technical
conditions we just used a couple of them
right so I pre muted limit an integral
you can check that we know really what
you want is that these integral of a
derivative is equal to zero well just
means that the values that the two ends
are actually the same right so those are
slightly different things so now what we
have is that the maximum likelihood
estimator has the following two
properties the first one if I were to
say that in words what would I say that
theta hat is is what yeah that's what I
would say when I read that for
mathematicians very famous statistician
what am I gonna say it's consistent
right so consistent estimator of theta
star converges in probability to theta
all right and then we have this sort of
central limit theorem statement right
the central limit theorem statement
tells me that if this was an average and
I removed the expectation of the average
let's say zero for example then square
root of n times the average blaah goes
to some normal distribution this is
telling you that this is actually true
even if they tahat there's nothing to do
with an average that's remarkable theta
hat might not even have a closed form
and I'm still having basically the same
properties as an average that would be
given to me by a central limit theorem
and what is the synthetic variance right
that's the variance in the end so here
I'm thinking of having those guys being
multivariate and so I have the inverse
of the covariance matrix that shows up
as the variance covariance matrix is
emphatically but if you think of just
being a one dimensional parameter it's
one over this Fisher information one
over the curvature so if the curvature
is really flat the variance becomes
really big if the curvature if the
function is really flat curvature is low
variance is big if the curvature is very
high the variance becomes very low and
so that illustrates everything that's
happening with the pictures that we have
and if you look what's amazing here
there's no square root 2 pi there's no
little fudge factors going on here this
is the asymptotic variance nothing else
it's all in there
all in the curvature all right and are
there any questions about this so you
can see here that theta star is the true
parameter and the information matrix is
evaluated at theta star that's the point
that matters right when I drew this
picture the point that was at the very
bottom was always theta star it's the
one that minimizes the K of divergence
you know so long as I'm as long as I'm
identified yes
no they hire the Fisher information
itself so the variant the inverse is
gonna be smaller
right so small variance is good so now
what it means actually if I look at what
is the quadratic risk of this guy
asymptotically what is the synthetic
quadratic risk
well it's zero actually but if I look at
if I assume that this thing is true that
this thing is pretty much Gaussian if I
look at the quadratic risk well it's the
expectation of the square of this thing
and so it's going to scale like the
variance divided by n okay the bias goes
to zero just by this and then and then
the the quadratic risk is going to scale
like one over Fisher information divided
by n okay so here the I'm not mentioning
the constants there must be constants
because everything is asymptotic so for
each finite n I'm gonna have some
constants that show up okay everybody
just got their mind blown by this
amazing theorem all right so I mean
honestly think about it
the MLE can be anything okay I'm sorry
to say to you in many instances the ML H
is gonna be an average which is just
gonna be slightly annoying alright but
there are some cases where it's not and
we have to resort to this theorem rather
than actually resorting to the central
limit theorem to prove this thing and
more importantly even if I if this was
an average you don't have to even know
how to compute the covariance matrix the
sorry the variance of this thing to go
to plug it into the central limit
theorem it's actually tool I'm telling
you it's actually given by the Fisher
information matrix alright so if it's an
average between you and me you probably
want to go the central limit theorem
route if you want to prove this kind of
stuff but if it's not then that's your
best shot but you have to check those
conditions I will give you for granted
the 0.5 all right okay ready
any questions we're gonna wrap up this
chapter 4 so if you have questions
that's the time yes
you mean the definition
well you see the quadratic risk if I
think of it as being one-dimensional
okay the quadratic risk is the
expectation of the square of the
difference between theta hat and theta
star okay so that means that if I think
of this as having a normal 0 1 that's
basically computing the expectation of
the square of this Gaussian divided by n
right I just divide by an a by square
root of n on both sides so it's the
expectation of the square of this
Gaussian the Gaussian is mean 0 so the
expectation of the square is just a
variance and so I'm left with 1 over the
Fisher information divided by n ok all
right so let's move on to chapter 4 and
this is the method of moments all right
so the method of moments is actually
maybe a bit older than maximum
likelihood maximum likes he would say
stated say early 20th century I mean as
a systematic thing because as I said
many of those guys are gonna be averages
so finding an average is probably a
little older the method of moments
there's some really nice uses there's a
paper by Pearson in 1904 I believe or
maybe 1894 I don't know
then we're in this paper he was actually
studying some species of crab in an
island and he was trying to make some
measurements that's how he came up with
this model of mixtures of gaussians
because there was actually two different
populations in this populations of crab
and and the way he actually fitted the
parameters by he was by doing the method
of moments except that since there were
a lot of parameters he actually had to
basically solve 6 6 equations with 6
unknowns and that was a complete
nightmare and the guy did it by hand and
we don't know how I did it actually but
that's that is pretty impressive alright
so I want to start and this first part
is a little brutal all right but this is
a course 18 class and I do not want to
give you right so let's all agree that
this course might be slightly more
challenging than ap statistics all right
and that means that it's gonna be
challenging just during class
I'm not gonna ask you about the virus
stress approximation theorem during the
exams but what I want you is to give you
mathematical motivations for what we're
doing all right and I can promise you
that maybe you will you know have a
slightly higher body temperature during
the the lecture but you will come out
smarter of this class okay and I'm
trying to motivate to you for using
mathematical tool and show you were
interesting mathematical things that you
might find dry elsewhere actually work
very beautifully in the in the stats
literature right then one that we saw
was using cubic libor divergence at a
motivation for maximum likelihood
estimation for example so the very
stress approximation theorem is
something that comes from pure analysis
all right so maybe I mean I took me a
while before I saw that and essentially
what it's telling you is that if you
look at a function that's continuous on
a an interval a B alright on a segment a
B then you can actually approximately
approximate it uniformly well by
polynomials as long as you're willing to
take the degree of this polynomial large
enough all right so the formal statement
is for any epsilon there exists the D
that depends on epsilon and a 1 to 80
all right so if you insist on having an
accuracy which is 1 over 10 to the 1
over 10,000 maybe you're gonna need a
polynomial of degree you know 100,000
who knows it doesn't tell you anything
about this but it's telling you that at
least you have only a finite number of
parameters to approximate those
functions that typically require an
infinite number of parameters to be
described ok so that's actually quite
nice and that's the basis for many
things and many polynomial methods
typically but and so here it's just an
its uniform so there's this max over X
that shows up that's actually a nice as
well ok that's very stressed proximation
theorem why is it useful to us well in
statistics I have a sample of X 1 X n I
have a say unifies the circle model I'm
not always gonna remind you that it's a
you know identified not unified
identified statistical model and I'm
gonna assume that it has a density all
right
you could think of it as having a PMF
but think of it as having a density for
one second now what I want is to
find the distribution okay I want to
find theta and finding theta since it's
identified is equivalent to finding P
theta which is equivalent to finding F
theta and knowing a function is the same
as knowing a density is the same as
knowing a density against any test
function H ok so that means that if I
want to know if I want to make sure I
know a density if I want to check if two
densities are the same all I have to do
is to compute their integral or against
all bounded continuous functions okay
that would you already know that it
would be true if I check for all
functions H but since F is a density I
can actually look only at functions H
that are bounded and say between 0 and 1
and minus 1 and 1 and that are
continuous ok that's enough agree well
just trust me on this
yes your question
yeah I can do that well I'm just finding
a characterization that's gonna be
useful for me later on right I can't
find a bunch of them but here this one
is going to be useful all right so all I
need to say is that if theta star
integrated against X H of X so this
implies that F is if theta is equal to F
theta star not everywhere but almost
everywhere okay and that's only true if
I guarantee to you that F theta and F
theta stores or densities this is not
true for any function ok so now that
means that well if I wanted to estimate
theta hat all I would have to do is to
compute the average right so this guy
here the integral let me clean up a bit
my board okay so I want to find so my
goal is to find theta such that I look
at f theta and now I integrate it
against H of X then this gives me the
same thing as if I were to do it against
F theta star ok and I want this for any
H which is continuous and bounded ok so
of course I cannot I don't know what
this quantity is it depends on my
imitator store but I have data from this
and I'm gonna do the usual the good old
Cystic trick which as well this I can
write as the expectation with respect to
P theta star of H theta max right that's
just the integral of a function against
something and so what I can do is say
well now I don't know this guy but my
good old trick from the book has
replaced expectations by averages and
what I get
okay and that's approximately by the law
of large numbers okay so if I can
actually find a function f theta such
that when I integrate it against H it
gives me pretty much the average of the
H evaluations of H over my data points
for all H then that should be a good
candidate okay the problem is that's a
lot of functions to try okay even if we
reduced it from all possible functions
to bound it and continues once that's
still a pretty large infinite number of
and so what we can do is to use our very
stress approximation theorem and says
well maybe I don't need to test it
against all H maybe the polynomials are
enough for me okay so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to look only at
functions H better of the form sum of a
kay so H of X is sum of a K X to the K
for K equals 0 to D only polynomials of
degree D okay so when I look at the
average of my H's I'm gonna get a term
like the first one right so the first
one here this guy becomes 1 over n sum
from I equal 1 to N sum from k equals 0
to D of a KX I to the K okay that's just
the average of the values of H of X I
and now what I need to do is to check
that it's true when I it's the same
thing when I integrate H of this form as
well I want this to hold for all
polynomials of degree D but still a lot
of them there's still an infinite number
of polynomials because there's an
infinite number of numbers a 0 to a D
that describe those polynomials but
since those guys are polynomial it's
actually enough for me to look only at
the terms in four of the form X to the K
no linear combination no nothing so
actually it's enough to look only at H
of X
which is equal to X to the K for K
equals 0 to D and now how many of those
guys are there just D plus 1 0 to D so
that's actually a much easier thing for
me to solve now this quantity which is
the integral of f theta
against X K X to the K so that's the
expectation of X to the K here is called
moment of order K or Kate moment of P
theta that's a moment a moment is just
the expectation of the power the mean is
which moment the first moment all right
and variance is not exactly the second
moment it's the second moment minus the
first moment squared right that's the
variance is e of x squared minus e of x
squared ok so those are things that you
already know and then you can go higher
you can go to your actual QV of x blah
blah here I say go to e of X to the D
now as you can see this is not something
you can really action it and put in
action right now because the virus dress
approximation theorem does not tell you
what these should be actually we totally
lost track of the epsilon that was even
looking for it just at approximately
equal approximately equal and so all
this thing is really just motivation but
it's essentially telling you that if you
go to D large enough technically you
should be able to identify exactly your
distribution up to Epsilon
alright so I should be pretty good if I
go to D large enough now in practice
this should actually there should be
much less than you know arbitrarily
large D typically we're gonna need D
which is one or two okay so there are
some limitations to this virus trust
approximation theorem right and there's
a few the first one is that it only
works for continuous functions which is
not so much of a problem that can be
fixed well we need bounded continuous
functions it works only on intervals
that's annoying right because we're
gonna have remember
criminals that are defined beyond
intervals so we need something that just
goes beyond the intervals and you can
imagine that if you let your functions
being huge it's gonna be very hard for
you to have a polynomial approximately
uniformly well things are gonna start
going up and down at the boundary and
it's gonna be very hard and again as I
said several times it doesn't tell us
what this should be and as a
statisticians were looking for methods
not like principles of existence of a
method that exists
all right so if is discrete I can
actually get a handle on this D if is
discrete and actually finite okay I'm
gonna actually look at a finite e
meaning that I have a PMF on say our
possible values X 1 to XR my random
variable capital X can take only our
possible values let's think of them as
being the integer numbers 1 to R okay
that's the number of success out of air
our trials that I get for example ok
binomial our P that's exactly something
like this all right so now clearly this
entire distribution is defined by the
PMF which gives me exactly our numbers
so I can completely describe this
distribution with our numbers the
question is do I have an enormous amount
of redundancy if I try to describe the
distribution using moments right it
might be that I need say R is equal to
10 maybe I have only 10 numbers to
describe this thing but I actually need
to compute moments up to the order of
hundred before I actually recover
entirely distribution maybe I need to go
infinite maybe the virus trash theorem
is the only thing that actually saves me
here and I just cannot recover it
exactly I can go to epsilon if I'm
willing to go to higher and higher
polynomials oh by the way in the veritas
approximation theorem I can promise you
that as epsilon goes to 0 D goes to
infinity all right so now really I don't
even have actually our parameters I have
only our -1 parameter because the last
one because they sum up to 1 okay so the
last one I can always get by doing 1
minus the sum of the first are fr minus
1 first
agreed so each distribution our numbers
is described by our minus
parameters okay the question is can I
use only our -1 moments describe this
guy okay this is something called
Gaussian curd rat the quadrature the
Gaussian quadrature tells you yes
moments are actually a good way to
reaper ammeter eyes your distribution in
the sense that if I give you the moments
or if I give you the probability mass
function and basically giving you
exactly the same information you can
recover all the probabilities from there
okay so here I'm going to denote by I'm
gonna drop the notation in theta all
right I don't have any theta here I'm
talking about any generic distribution
and so I'm gonna call em K the cake
moment okay and if I have a PMF this is
really the sum for K equals sorry for J
equals 1 to R of X J to the are sorry to
the K sorry X J to the K times P of XJ
okay and this is the PMF all right so
that's my calf moment so the case moment
is a linear combination of the numbers
that I'm interested in so I also have so
that's that's one equation okay and I
have as many equations as I'm actually
willing to look at moments so if I'm
looking at 25 moments I have 25
equations okay
each M 1 equals blah with this to the
power 1 and Q equals bar with this to
the power 2 etcetera and then I also
have the equation that 1 is equal to the
sum of the pjs of the P of XJ okay
that's just the definition of a PMF okay
so this is ours they're ugly but those
are hard okay so now this is a system of
linear equations in P and I can actually
write it in its canonical form which is
of the form a matrix of those guys times
my parameters of interest is equal to a
right hand side
the right-hand side is the moments that
means if I give you the moments
can you come back and find what the PMF
is because we know already from
probability that the PMF is all I need
to know to fully describe my
distribution given the moments that's
unclear now here I have I'm gonna
actually take exactly R minus 1 moments
and this extra condition that the sum of
those guys should be 1 okay so that
gives me our equations based on R minus
1 moments and how many unknowns do I
have well I have my are unknown
parameters okay for the PMF that are our
values of the PMF now of course this is
going to play a huge role in whether
there are many peas that satisfy that
give me the same right the goal is to
find if there are several peas that can
give me the same moments but if there's
only one pea that can give me a set a
moment that means that I have a
one-to-one correspondence between PMF
and moments and so if you give me the
moments I can just go back to the to the
PMF now how do I go back well by
inverting this matrix right if I
multiply this matrix by its inverse I'm
gonna get identity times the vector of P
is time the inverse of equality inverse
of the matrix times the MS okay so what
we want to do is to say that P is equal
to the inverse of this big matrix times
the moment that you give me and if I can
actually talk about the inverse then I
have basically a one-to-one mapping
between the MS the moments and the
matrix so what I need to show is that
this matrix is invertible and we just
decided that we the way to check if a
matrix is invertible is by computing its
determinant who has computed the
determinant before who was supposed to
computer determinant at least then just
to say no maybe not to do it but so you
know how to compute determinants and if
you've seen any determinants in class
there's one that shows up in the
exercise the professor's love and it's
called the vandermonde determinate and
it's the determinant of a matrix that
have a very specific form
it looks like so there's basically only
our parameters to this R by R matrix the
first row or the first column sometimes
it's presented like that
is this vector where each entry is to
the power of 1 and the second one is
each entries to the power 2 and to the
power of 3 n to the power 4 etc okay so
that's exactly what we have X 1 to the 1
X 2 to the 1 all the way to X R to the 1
and then same thing to the power 2 all
the way to the last one and I also need
to add the row of all ones which you can
think of those guys at the to the power
is 0 if you want so I should really put
it on top if I wanted to have a nice
ordering okay so that was the matrix
that I had and I'm not asking you to
check it you can prove that by induction
actually typically by doing the usual
let's eliminate some rows and columns
type of tricks that you do for matrices
you basically start from the whole
matrix and then you move on to a matrix
that has only one ones and then zeros
here and then you have a vandermonde
that's just slightly smaller and then
you just iterate yeah
yeah I know but I don't think the answer
to your question is yes s'okay is
generic index right so there's no KK
does not exist K just is here for me to
tell me for K equals 1 to R so this is
an R by R matrix and so there's no K
there right so I'm just if you wanted
the generic term if I wanted to put 1 in
the middle on the J throw and Cate
column that would be X so J throw would
be X to the X sub K to the power J 2
power J that would be there okay and so
now this is basically the sum well there
should not be strictly right so that
would be for J with J and K between 1
and R so this is the formula you get
when you try to expand this vendor mom
determinant you have to do it only once
when you're a sophomore typically and
then you can just go on Wikipedia to do
it that's what I did I actually made a
mistake copying it the first one should
be 1 less than or equal to J and the
last one should be K less than or equal
to R and now what you have is the
product of the differences of XG and XK
all right and for this thing to be done
0 you need all the terms to be nonzero
and for all the terms to be nonzero you
need to have no X I XJ and no XJ XK
they're identical if all those are
different numbers then this product is
going to be different from 0 and those
are different numbers because those are
the are possible values that your random
variable takes you're not going to say
that it takes two with probability one
point five I'm sorry - it's probably 0.5
and 2 with probability point 75 point 25
you're gonna say it takes 2 with
probability point 75 directly all right
so this is those eggs J's are different
these are the different values that your
random variable can take ok
remember XJ XK was just the different
values X 1 to XR sorry was the different
values that your random variable can
take nobody in their right mind would
write twice the same value in this list
okay so my vendor bound is nonzero so I
can invert it and I have a one-to-one
correspondence between my entire pm
and the first or minus ones moments to
which I append the number one which is
really the moment of order zero again
it's a of X to the 0 which is 1
ok so good news I only need R minus 1
parameters to describe our minus 1
parameters and I can choose either the
values of my PMF or I can choose them R
minus 1 first moments okay so the
moments tell me something right here it
tells me that if I have a discrete
distribution with our possible values I
only need to compute our minus 1 moments
so I have this is better than virus
proximation theorem this tells me
exactly how many moments I need to
consider and this is for any
distribution this is not a distribution
that's parameterize by one parameter
like the person or the binomial or all
this stuff right this is for any
distribution on the finite number so
hopefully if I reduce the family of PMF
that I'm looking at to a one-parameter
family I'm actually going to need to
compute much less than our minus 1
values okay but this is actually hopeful
it tells you that the method of moments
is going to work for any distribution
just have to invert a vandermonde matrix
ok so just the conclusion the
statistical conclusions is that moments
contain important information right
about the PMF and the PDF we can
estimate if we can estimate this moment
securely we can solve for the parameters
of the distribution and recover the
distribution and in a parametric setting
we're knowing P theta amounts to knowing
theta which is identifiability right
this is not innocuous it is often the
case that even less moments or needed
right after all if theta is a one
dimensional parameter I have one
parameter to estimate why would I go and
get 25 moments to get this one parameter
typically there's actually we will see
that the method of moments just says if
you have a d-dimensional parameter just
compute the moments and that's it all
right and so but this is only on the
case-by-case basis right I mean maybe
your model or totally
screw up its parameters and you actually
need to get them right I mean think
about it if the function is
parameterized just by its 27th moment
like that's the only thing that matters
in this distribution I just described a
function it's just a density and the
only thing that can change from one
distribution to another it's the 27th
moment well then you're gonna have to go
get the 27th moment that probably means
that you're modeling step was actually
pretty bad okay
okay so the rule of thumb if theta is in
our D we need the moments okay so what
is the meta moments it's just a good old
trick okay
replace the expectation by averages
right that's the beauty the moments are
expectations so let's just replace
expectations by averages and then do it
with the average version as if it was
the true one okay so for example my I'm
gonna talk about population moments when
I'm computing them with the true
distribution and I'm going to talk about
empirical moments when I talk about
averages okay so those are the two
quantities that I have and now what I
hope is that there is alright so this is
basically everything is here that's
where all the money is I'm going to
assume there's a function sigh that
map's my parameters let's say they're in
RD to the set of the first d moments
right well what I want to do is to come
from this guy back to theta so it better
be that this function is invertible
right I want this function to be
invertible in the vandermonde case this
function was just a linear function
multiplied Ceyda
a matrix by theta then inverting a
linear function is inverting the matrix
then this is the same thing alright so
now what I'm gonna assume and that's key
for this method to work is that this
theta is a so this function side is
one-to-one there's only one data that
gets only one set of
of moments okay and so if it's
one-to-one I can talk about its inverse
and so now I'm going to be able to
define theta as the inverse of the
moments okay
the reciprocal of the moments and so now
what I get is that the moment estimator
is just the thing where rather than took
it taking the true guys in there I'm
actually gonna take the empirical
moments in there okay before we go any
further I'd like to just go back and
tell you that this is not completely
free right how well-behaved your
function side is going to play a huge
role if I give you if I can somebody
tell me what the typical distance if I
have a sample of size n what is the
typical distance between an average and
the expectation what is it the typical
distance what is the order of magnitude
as a function of n between xn bar and
its expectation 1 over square root n
that's what the central limit theorem
tells us right the central limit theorem
tells us that those things are basically
a Gaussian which is of order 1 divided
by a square root of N ok and so
basically I start with something which
is 1 over square root of n away from the
true thing now if my function psi
inverse is super steep like this
alright that's sy inverse then just both
fluctuations even if they're of order 1
over square root of n can translate into
giant fluctuations in the y-axis right
and that's just that's going to be
controlled by how steep
sian verse is which is the same as
saying how flat sy is alright how flat
sy so if you go back to this vandermonde
inverse what it's telling you is that if
this inverse matrix blows up this guy a
lot ok so if I start from a small
fluctuation of this thing and then
they're blown up
by applying the inverse of this matrix
things are not gonna go well anybody
knows what is the number that I should
be looking for so that's from say
numerical linear algebra numerical
methods
what is the when I have a system of
linear equations what is the actual
number I should be looking at to know
how much I'm blowing up the fluctuations
yeah
the condition number right so what's
important here is the condition number
of this matrix if the condition number
of this matrix is small then it's good
it's not gonna blow up much but if the
condition number is very large it's just
gonna blow up a lot and the condition
number is the ratio of the largest and
the smallest eigen values okay so you'll
have to know what it is but this is how
all this thing's get together so the
stability the numerical stability
translates into statistical stability
here and amiracle means just if I had
errors in measuring the right hand side
how much would the translate into errors
on the left hand side so the air here is
intrinsic to statistical questions okay
so that's my estimator provided it
exists okay and I said it's a one-to-one
so it should exist if I assume that size
is invertible okay so how good is this
guy all right that's gonna be definitely
our question how good is this thing and
as I said there's chances that if psy is
really steep then it should be not very
good EPSA inverse is very steep it's not
it should not be very good which means
that it's well let's just leave it to
that and and so that means that I should
probably see the derivative of psy
showing up somewhere right if the
derivative of sine inverse a is very
large then I should actually have a
larger variance in my estimator so
hopefully just like we had an estimate
we had a theorem that told us that the
Fisher information was key in the
variance of the maximum likelihood
estimator we should have a theorem that
tells us that the derivative of sine
inverse is gonna have a key role in the
method of moments so let's do it
all right so I'm gonna talk about
matrices so now I have so since I'm a
1/2 sorry I have to manipulate D numbers
at any given time just gonna concatenate
them into a vector okay so I'm gonna
call capital M theta so that's basically
right so that's the population moment
and I have M hat which is just M hat 1/2
M hat D and that's my empirical moments
ok and what's gonna play a role is what
is the variance the the variance
covariance of the random vector ok so I
have this vector 1 ok so that's a D
dimensional vector and here I take the
successive powers right remember that
looks very much like a column of my of
my vendor mom matrix okay so now I have
this random vector it's just the
successive powers of some random
variable X and the variance covariance
matrix is the expectation so Sigma of
theta the theta just means I'm going to
take expectations with respect to theta
that the expectation with respect to
theta of this guy times this guy
transpose
- the same thing but with the
expectation inside
why do I do X x1 I have X X 2 X 3 ok
X X 2 XD times the expectation of X X 2
XD okay everybody sees what this is so
this is a matrix where if I look at the
IJ term of this matrix let's say JK term
so on row J and column K I have Sigma JK
of theta and it's simply the expectation
of X to the J plus K well like GX k
minus expectation of XJ expectation of X
K okay so I can write this as M J plus K
theta minus M J of theta times MK of
theta okay
so that's my that's my covariance matrix
of this particular vector that I I
define and now I'm gonna assume that psy
inverse well if I want to talk about
this slope in an analytic fashion I have
to talk about the assumed that size is
differentiable and I will talk about the
gradient of spy which is if it's
one-dimensional it's just the derivative
and here that's where a notation becomes
annoying and I'm gonna actually just
assume that so now I have a vector but I
want to compute it's a vector of
functions and I want to compute those
functions at a particular value and the
value I'm actually interested in is at
the I'm afraid of wrong
okay so psy inverse goes from the set of
moments to the set of parameters so when
I look at the gradient of this guy it
should be a function that takes as
inputs moments and where do I want this
function to be a value
yet at the true moment at the population
moment vector okay
just like when I computed my Fisher
information on was computing it at the
true parameter okay so now once I
compute this guy so now why is this a D
by D gradient matrix all right so I have
a gradient vector when I have a function
from already to R this is the partial
derivatives right but now I have a
function from Rd to R D so I have to
take the derivative with respect to the
arrival coordinate and the departure
coordinate okay and so that's the
gradient matrix and now I have the
following properties the first one is
that the law of large number tells me
that far as that theta hat is a weakly
or strongly consistent estimator okay so
either I use the strong lower number or
the weak law of large number and I get
stronger weak consistency okay so what
does that mean it why is that true well
because now I really have a function of
so I really have the function right so
what is my estimator theta hat is Phi
inverse of M hat 1/2 M hat K okay now by
the law of large numbers let's sleep
only at the weak one okay law of large
number tells me that each of the empty
hat so MJ hat is going to converge in
probability as n goes to infinity to D
so the empirical moments converge to the
population moments all right that's what
the good old trick is using the fact
that the empirical moments are close to
the true moments as n becomes larger and
that's because well just because the M
had J's or averages and the lower that
number works for averages okay so now if
I plus if I look my continuous mapping
theorem
then they have that size is concise
inverse is continuous it's continuously
differentiable so it's definitely
continuous and so what I have is that
Sai inverse of M hat 1 and hat D
converges to sai inverse M 1 to M D
which is equal to of theta star so
that's theta star by definition we
assumed that that was the unique one
that was actually doing this again this
is this is a very strong assumption I
mean it's basically saying if the method
amoment works it works okay so this this
the fact that psy inverse is one-to-one
is really the key to making this guy
work and then I also have a central
limit theorem and the central limit
theorem is basically telling me that M
hat is converging to M even in the
multivariate sense so if I look at the
vector of M hat and the true vector of M
then I actually make them go I look at
the difference rescale by square root of
n it goes to some Gaussian and usually
we would see if it was one dimensional
which see the variance then we see the
variance covariance matrix who has never
seen them well nobody answers this
question who has already seen the
multivariate central limit theorem okay
who has never seen this enough to very
central it there okay so the
multivariate central limit theorem is
basically just the slight extension of
the univariate one it just says that if
I want to think so the multi the
univariate one would tell me something
like this
and zero and then I would have basically
the variance of X to the K X to the J
alright so that's what the central limit
theorem tells me okay this is an average
okay so this is just for averages the
central me theorem tells me this
just think of X to the J as being why
that would be true everybody agrees with
me so now this is actually telling
what's happening for all these guys
individually but what happens when those
guys start to correlate together I'd
like to know if they actually correlate
the same way it's emphatically and so if
I actually looked at the covariance
matrix of this vector okay so now I need
to look at a matrix which is D by D then
with those univariate central limit
theorems tell me so if I look at so let
me write like this right double bar so
that's just the covariance matrix
okay this notation V double bar is the
variance covariance matrix so what this
thing tells me so I know this thing this
thing is the matrix D by D those
univariate central limit theorem is only
give me information about the diagonal
terms right but here I have no idea what
the covariance matrix is this guy is
telling me that this guy is telling me
for example that this thing is like
variance of X to the J but what if I
want to find the of diagonal elements of
this matrix well I need to use a
multivariate central limit theorem and
really what it's telling me is that you
can actually replace this guy here
so that goes in distribution to some
normal mean zero again and now what I
have is just Sigma of theta which is
just the covariance matrix of this
vector X X 2 X 3 X 4 all the way to XD
and that's it so that's a multivariate
Gaussian who has never seen a
multivariate Gaussian okay please just
go and Wikipedia or something there's
not much to know about it but I don't
have time to redo for ability here so
we're gonna have to live with it now to
be fair if your goal is not to become a
statistical savant we will stick to
univariate questions in the scope of
homework and and exams okay all right so
now what was the the Delta method
telling me I was telling me that if I
had a central limit theorem that told me
that theta hat was going to theta or
square root of n theta hat minus theta
was going to some Gaussian then I could
look at square root of Mg of theta hat
minus G of theta and this thing was also
going to Gaussian but what I had to pay
is the square of the derivative of G in
the SM in the in the parents okay all
right so the Delta method was just it
was just a way to go from square root of
n theta hat n minus theta goes to sum
and say 0 Sigma squared 2 so Delta
method was telling me that this was
heard of n G of theta hat n minus G of
theta was going to in distribution to n
0 Sigma squared G square G prime squared
of theta ok that was the Delta method
now here we have a function of those
guys right the central living theorem
even the multivariate one is only
guaranteeing something for me regarding
the moments
but now I need to map the moments back
into some theta so have a function of
the moments and there's something called
a multivariate Delta method where
derivatives are replaced by gradients
like they always are in multivariate
calculus and rather than multiplying
since things do not commute rather than
choosing which side I want to keep it
would site I want to put the square I'm
actually just gonna take half of the
square on one side at the other half of
the square on the one on the other side
okay so the way you should view this
should think of Sigma squared times G
prime squared as being G prime of theta
times Sigma squared times G prime of
theta ok and now this is completely
symmetric and and the multivariate the
multivariate Delta method is basically
telling you that you get the gradient
here so you start from something that's
like that over there a sigma so that's
my Sigma square think of Sigma square
and then I pre multiply by the gradient
and post multiply by the gradient the
first one is transposed the second one
is not but that's various true very
straightforward extension I didn't have
to understand it let's just think of
what would be the natural generalization
here by the way I wrote explicitly what
the gradient of a multivariate function
is so that's a function that goes from
our D to our K ok so now the gradient is
a D by K matrix okay and so now for this
guy we can do it for the method of
moments and we can see that basically
we're going to have this scaling that
depends on the gradient of the
reciprocal of psy which is normal
because if psy is super steep if sine
inverse is super steep then the gradient
is going to be huge which is going to
translate in having a huge variance that
for the method of moments okay so this
is actually the end I would like to
encourage you and we'll probably do it
on Thursday just to start but I
encourage you do it in one dimension so
that you're you can know how to use the
method of moments you know how to do a
bunch of things do it in one dimensions
and see that how you can check those
things so just as a quick comparison in
terms of the quadratic Chris the maximum
likelihood estimator is typically more
accurate than the method of moments what
you what is pretty good to do is when
you have a non convex non concave
likelihood function what people like to
do is to start with the method of
moments as an initialization and then
run some algorithm that optimizes
locally the likelihood starting from
this point because it's actually likely
to be closer and then the MLE is going
to improve it a little bit by pushing
the likelihood it a little better
okay so of course the maximum likelihood
is sometimes intractable whereas
computing moments is fairly doable if
the likelihood is concave as I said we
can use optimization algorithms such as
interior point methods or gradient
ascent I guess to maximize it and if the
likelihood is non concave we only have
local heuristics and that's what I meant
you have only local maxima and one trick
you can do so your likelihood looks like
this and it might be the case that you
would have if you want it if you have a
lot of those Peaks you basically have to
start your algorithm in each of those
Peaks but the maximum the method of
moments can actually start you in the
right peak and then you just move up by
doing some local algorithm for maximum
likelihood okay so that's not P but
that's just if you want to think about
algorithmically how would I end up doing
this and how can I combine the two all
right so I'll see you on Thursday
thank you